thank you uh yasser we are here with a
man that needs absolutely uh no
introduction the 13th world champion and
the patron of the grand chester mr gary
casper of gary first of all welcome back
to the show we haven't seen you since
romania
long time tell us a bit what have you
been doing in those last uh few days
um yeah i uh flew from romania just you
know one
event in europe so
in switzerland then back to america it
was a few very busy days and then flew
here you know to poland so it's the
life is busy
mostly this of course it's it's
interviews and all the events they are
related to politics to ukraine uh but
there's always room for chess so and and
for uh
other things like you know machines uh
decision making uh
uh
ai so it's the yeah i
i
never suffer from lack of attention
absolutely let's start with the
beginning yesterday we had an amazing
opening ceremony tell us about your
first impressions of that as well as
round number one
look i think it's uh it's very natural
to have a big event in warsaw now poland
is now uh
chess powerhouse um it's not just
younger shadow
it's its overall rise of interest for
the
game and um you know i
i thought it was you know just it's a
it's a great location uh it's it's we we
know that superbed
has been trying and very successfully to
to set up new standards for organizing
events in europe so we we know that
saint louis now had its uh it's its
standards but uh i could i could see now
and everybody can see that that's
superbed is doing absolutely everything
to make sure that europe will be on par
with america in in paying respect and
how much to the game and the players
tell us a bit about this partnership
super bad is a new partner for all three
uh tour stops here in europe tell us
about that and the development of this
new partnership
look uh we know that super bet has been
founded by sasha druggage a former chess
player so and uh and it's uh it's um was
a fuel accidental meeting i had with him
in bucharest
having one event it was a dinner and uh
and then he just
he called me and said so
probably you know i could do more for
the game of chess
super bet was rising uh uh it's getting
bigger and bigger and
and we superbed growing in size uh so
the
the appetites to support chess also
growing so it's a it's a match made in
heaven um
i think we had probably one of the
strongest chess sponsors in history
somebody who played at the master level
in in in in former yugoslavia and now
is is very happy to see how chess
is being promoted of course their
area of interest so far is is eastern
europe but i believe it could be
expanded and
and i think that the european segment of
granchester is safe for many years to
come one thing that i really love seeing
whenever i come to the opening ceremony
of this tours as well as the rounds you
see a lot of young participants in the
opening ceremony in the simuls what is
the impact that this tour has on those
young aspiring players look it's it's a
part of the philosophy of superbed but
it's also as part of my own uh uh
promotional philosophy it's uh it's the
combining the granchester activities
with cosporochess foundation activities
and uh
superb
now is is uh i'm very aggressive
pursuing the
um
chess um
uh
educational programs uh in
in in romania so i think it's uh
it's it's just a matter of time before
they succeed in just in putting chess in
romanian schools and we could see that's
in other countries like poland so uh
it's
it's not
centralized but in many parts of poland
you already you already have chess
programs and and these two trends they
they have to work
in synergy so you you need public
interest you need kids getting in the
game uh to offer uh incentives for
sponsors but also you know just as this
is you need them for you know to find
talent so it's a it's um
it's a self-sustaining
sustaining system and
and uh poland probably is now is it's
most likely it's still a leading country
in eastern europe but i will not be
surprised to see romania also catching
up soon and then again this is when you
have few countries just making so much
progress i'm sure the others will will
try to also to to
catch up in this tournament we have six
wild cards and once again the emphasis
is on youth how important it is for guys
like kiril shevchenko david gavrilasko
to play against the best chess players
in on the planet at this stage in their
careers you know i think it's again it's
very natural choice because chess is
getting younger
and
and
[Music]
one of the problems of ranches too or
many
events of that type was that oh we had
the same faces you know moving from one
place to another it's like you know like
like a circus uh and having
young players there may not may not be
at this you know yet at that level but
it just offers them an opportunity so
that's that's the way to to
to bring them in and just to to to to
train them but also it creates more
excitement because uh it's it's
people like to see new faces so we still
have old usual suspects but it's great
you know we have kerosene change and we
shannon you know playing in the same
tournament so i'm really really happy to
see that you know we we are now here
just you know bringing the genera
players were generations generations
apart
absolutely and speaking of excitement we
came from romania and we were seeing
three four draws per round
it was classical that was classical of
course in this one we started off with
almost all decisive games the last one
between wesley was uh and korobov was a
draw but that one was very close to
being a decisive one as well now let's
go through the games what the game uh
did you have your eyes on
yeah the uh the the first game i looked
at was uh the duda gabrielescu
yeah it's you know it's interesting
played very quick very uh um
uh
it's
quickly
and um i don't know and and i but but
but dude also just that was blitzing out
here blitzing
all these moves and again i i i would be
very concerned about black's position
here this but but abe like when you find
out after c4 i think he just you know he
stopped yes he stopped yes yeah but i
don't know where the position was that
bad naturally this is this something is
wrong you know just you you have to
develop your pieces you know in a more
uh
um
traditional fashion that's but still
there's one moment in the game that you
know just remains this is for me another
yes queen a5 b3 bishop the seven d5 do
the blade take take take take d okay
here that's the d take c6 yes
yeah and here i think it's a c plate b3
yes which is in there which i think it's
not a good move yes that's again but
that's what i
maybe the the only chance was
was knight c6 knight c6 absolutely
because this you have to develop the
pieces yes so and uh is this that clear
no absolutely not that's that's what i
just you know i i i looked at it because
i was doing my interviews there and i
said definitely
it's look bad but then i just see if you
play knight c6
yeah but you look at your pieces out
yeah but look at white pieces you know
rook on this is there's still you know
way behind it xf7 you can take all the
king of fade i don't know you can take
it one yeah already black seems to be
better nobody no but i know there's
stuff the knight c6 by the way black can
always you know this castle is still
short castle is still possible so and
after 96 you know it's important this
knight because this knight eventually
went on d4 and e6 so how can you keep an
eye on i would have played dancer six
you know just without even thinking
because without thinking
you develop
instinctively just
perhaps a lack of experience for the
young women
it seems like it maintains the balance
at least from what c5 was very
it's not an easy end game to defend yeah
but this is but then then again that's
here here you go the position that is
just you know that's the yeah it's uh
yeah
it's really hard to actually do it's
i'm not sure his position is okay yeah
it seems to be but you know
but you need but you need to to to to um
be a computer so yes
what's the what's that what was the only
move here
perhaps bishop to a3 would have been the
only move after cafe already immediately
not g5 yes 95 and the game collapses
yeah uh very difficult game for gary
lesko but a good start for the young
police superstar now let's go to this
game between uh i want to start with
this one chef chenkov versus rapport
yeah because we once again see another
french yes
this time with e5 and we follow this
variation and another striking thing was
that rapport was blitzing out his moves
while his opponent was burning quite a
lot of time
up to this point still within theory
i think that's theory yes
theory was also
not not not yet not yet i think we are
already out of theory i believe c4 was
the first move out of theory
yes so he played this move bishop to a
b8 quite fast richie that is and after
c4 he had his first thing with his move
a6
now
at this point shawshenko had only 16
minutes and it seems that he was
struggling how did you uh assess his
position
i don't know i just
look
if
white succeeds in destroying black
center it's really dangerous but after
a6 you know
he ended up sacrificing the piece he did
he played a move knight to c3 and by the
way he blitzed out this moves after
giving up his piece and unfortunately
played this move bishop to c5 quickly
which is a mistake
not b6 yes knight to b6 wasn't necessary
in this position but once again it's so
difficult to play right because you have
to actually take on d7 and then just
simply take on b5 it doesn't feel very
natural
yeah but it's probably it's the uh
it's probably the dynamic equality yes
yes i would yes yeah yes
yeah and he played this move bishop to
c5 after which it seems like a reporter
yes yeah
took over so a shaky start for chef
chenko now do you know kiril at all have
you been following his career up to this
point i think i just you know i played
him in the simultaneous ensemble in kiev
in
2014 i was at the end of the 2014 so he
was quite young yeah he was he was very
young so yeah it's it's it's it's a it's
very spectacular career or so and i
think he's is i don't know what he's
already the strongest ukrainian player
but he's definitely now going to to
going this way and i think this
tournament will be very helpful because
that's very important you know even if
you know what to do so you still
you you have to go through this test you
know playing all the best players in the
world and i think this tournament will
actually help him to to
to um reveal his true potential and one
more game that i do want to take the
pulse from you is this one the clash
between a man that you know so very well
anan versus vojtashek and they played
this
quick uh theoretical line is it
theoretical now it seems like it was
theoretical but uh it's uh voidershock
was playing really quickly and at this
point he had 26 minutes on the clock and
she only had 20 minutes five
f5
take take this is the moment vichy had
20 minutes and after this it just felt
like he took over
tell us about this how is he still
playing so well
i don't know it's that's it's uh it's
okay i remember wasting this mislove but
you know just
vishy but actually this is is is has
probably you know um
i know i'm thinking this whether
courtney
look salvation now is 53 years 50 is
recording
yes fortunately that's the only parallel
so but still you know i think vichy
is
is
doing
probably
as well probably even better and it's
not even only about the age but he's
quite inactive and he took second in
croatia now he starts off i think he is
you know that's important you know this
is probably his part of the character so
he's just you know he's uh
he he feels fine so he's not you know
yes at the end of the day chess is about
making decisions and it's there i think
she found this is the right approach to
the game so this is
it it counts as rapid chess so but just
he makes moves you know he's he he
doesn't work it does work so he's this
this calm and and and
and and his uh
the way just you know he just approaches
the game so i think it offers him you
know some kind of a yeah psycho
advantage and maybe it's also being felt
by the opponent so and and look he knows
how to put the pieces in right square so
that's that's you so here it is and it's
very quickly knight on the five knight
c6 911 and just you know all white
pieces arrived at the station on time
gary thank you very much for joining us
now before i let you go i'm going to put
you on the spot who's your favorite to
win this
i don't know i i think
young christoph yeah so he will be it's
it's home tour but
look it's anything can happen it's it's
a that's a tough event it's blitz so i
would yeah but i won't be surprised if
we it as well so this is yeah
but again it's it's it's it's this is
the the beauty about this tournament is
this you don't forget we have wesley so
we have levona
all of them can do really well so gary
always a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you very much and we'll see
you in the next few days
and we're actually going to go on a
break stay with us and we're going to
come back shortly